et évidemment ça la ram n'a pas mais il
faut absolument que lina soit pas morte
pour rien c'est vrai on peut pas
accepter sans sur ensemble surtout
surtout les jeunes qui nous regardent
oui c'est possible c'est les jeunes qui
nous regardent le harcèlement je vous
dis c'est un truc de lâches c'est un
truc de volos c'est pour les tocards je
vous dis c'est
c'est pas une fierté de harceler une
personne en difficulté une personne qui
est qui est différente la personne qui a
envie de vivre différemment de vous au
contraire je vous le dit ou passé pas
pour des roues
cc
c'est pitoyable
donc tous les harceleurs peut-être de
jeunes qui nous regardent
je vous dise et
si vous êtes tous au verrou
vraiment
et toucy à des personnes qui sont
harcelés n'hésitez pas dites le et soyez
forts dites le et vous savez c'est
peut-être des moments difficiles à
passer pendant qu'elle tombe et ça va
s'arranger après si vous parlez si vous
le dites si vous le fait savoir et s'ils
arrivent à faire bouger les choses et si
les choses bougent comme médina l'a dit
c'est vrai qu'il est exactement mais le
problème qui a sept vous voyez renvoyer
l'exemple de samira vous dit samira la
raison tout à l'heure je vous ai entendu
vous avez dit on a fait tout comme il
fallait parce que je savais que je
devais poser la question de talent je
vous ai dit vous étiez au courant vous
vous parlez beaucoup avec votre fille il
faut vraiment que les établissements il
faut vraiment que le gouvernement soit
beaucoup plus sensibles à ça beaucoup
plus sévère envers les établissements le
problème qui a dans les établissements
et giuly c'est ça qui est insupportable
c'est que les établissements sont notés
et que les établissements ils n'ont
qu'une trouille c'est d'avoir une
mauvaise note donc ils veulent pas faire
de bruit ils veulent pas faire le et il
va y mettre sous le tapis et ça c'est
inadmissible si peut-être qu'il faut
changer cette cette manière de noter les
établissements parce que c'est ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui il ya des drames qui
se passe parce que le les établissements
ils ont tellement peur d'avoir une dette
mal notés ils ont tellement peur que ça
fasse du bruit ils ont tellement peur
que ce soit médiatisé aujourd'hui j'ai
eu plein d'affaires comme ça et à chaque
fois les parents me disaient non mais
les professeurs nous dit hannon si vous
mettez attiser le truc on veut pas
didier hiel je vous le dis le même le
lycée où ma soeur elle était oui par
exemple moi je le dis on a fait la
marche blanche donc il ya des
organisateurs qui sont chargés de la
marche blanche qui nous ont rappelés
lycée pour les prévenir que la marche à
ça finira devant le lycée donc que les
roses et les fleurs et tout ce qui
s'ensuit à les déposer devant est la
principale du jc leur a dit mais une
fois que la marshall est finie vous
balayer trottoir vous en tous cas 2000
n'ont
pas être
satisfait c'est alors qu'on
n'a rien à voir avec le lycée au
contraire les élèves de 6es il se bat
depuis que ma soeur elle est morte pour
obtenir une minute de silence mais bon
ma soeur vu qu'elle était depuis trois
semaines scolarisés n'était pas connu ça
va remuer plus qu'autre chose les les
adolescents si on faisait quelque chose
alors c'est mieux qu'on fasse rire c'est
les paroles de de la principale du lycée